hi hey what's up I'm Mike that's Mary
it's true probably know who we are if
you've been watching this this is
resident Knievel episode 4 of code
Veronica X yeah so we've done all the
numbered series and now we're on to
bonus Knievel's so these are ones we
wanted to do for fun especially like
ones that people have been watching this
series or like oh you can't like not do
this and the number one game we heard
was you cannot do code Veronica
it's like so good so now we're doing
that I have to remember what happened
last time
a lot of [ __ ] went down I'm trying to
like not get it mixed up with the
episode before but essentially like
because there's like this submarine
thing that happened and I was like cool
we need like three pieces of like metal
or whatever to get like get into this
next section but if we're not talking
about that I met a bunch of like of
those giant long armed Fox Bandersnatch
'as oh what a horrible name I don't like
that name
it's my Saturday night all right and
they stretch their arms out and slap me
and there's like two now right outside
this building which is really upsetting
and then Steve gave me the golden guns I
gave him my Aziz he like shut up some
people we learned about his father
father
got really melodramatic it was so
beautiful and now I'm actually thinking
about my next steps I have this yellow
static so you did a sneak peek you still
haven't actually gone
technically in this save you haven't
gone through the Luger door but you all
right so you got those two new like a
Uzi submachine gun yes for it in fear I
have no what no that's it
where are those submachine guns go isn't
it
those oh no Steve still had them to use
him with Steve but I think you did miss
something back near Steve where he was
well shouldn't I go into that room
though with all the stuff yeah okay
and then what about this hemostatic
because that goes to that guy so when I
first started this game a guy like let
me out of the prison cell and he was
hurt and so he was like you you're gonna
want to like get some hemostatic to like
save him or some [ __ ] yeah remember yeah
I don't remember what he gives you but
it's probably worth doing it feels like
it's worth it alright let's just go
through Oh what's he doing standing
bloody victoriously over someone who's
killed it could be late but no that's a
head he's holding a head I think all
right so can you write this down thank
you
just do you like LR okay okay
you ready yep l are okay L okay are okay
RRR
okay
okay
left right left right right right right
oh I hate this video it's like it's like
the ring it's creepy it's so creepy it's
when they stare at each other it gets
real weird
Ashford's like this parts awful but then
it's this part right here okay
so creepy alright so then that turns
that on I guess weird please enter the
password and we don't have the password
right yet no I thought so I mean I I
know what it is for my memory if it's
Earth but yeah we don't technically have
it yet all right I don't think I know
can we go for a while and have don't get
at the mid we didn't I forgot okay
alright alright ready go left
uh-huh right
left right and then three rights
wait did I do it can I forget one right
no you did three left right
oh wait right I tried to get out reset
it no no we're gonna reset it you should
be good
I'm super confused so the numbers have
left right , so now right right maybe we
leave is that what you're saying I have
no idea oh okay write down the number 1
is that what it is so this is the first
number oh is that what it's saying
all right just break down one I don't
know and then the second number is the
second thing so what's that okay
what's that right okay so the second
number is nine that's my this is what
I'm thinking or oh it's the number but
you're not supposed to hit reset okay
that's okay I get it on something okay
so yes so left and then what
okay wait three what was that number
three right but isn't the first one left
right
oh I see you're saying so left right is
one okay and then the next one there's
one left
okay so it's one nine and then what's
next one right one nine seven one nine
seven one is my guess based on very
little so presumably this is the
password for that computer that's my
guess 1 1971 yes
score they explained it it still took me
a while to like get my [ __ ] together
oh my god demon children you don't
understand I don't have a lot of help I
don't I don't have a lot health I don't
have a lot of health I don't have a lot
of help
yeah it's Todd where's hands gonna on
the coffee I don't want him oh maybe he
reset [ __ ] I helped to do this Shai like
god damn it
like I'm on caution here like he's gonna
kill me what should I do
like I could just try to run through
that door yeah good Jim I'm gonna die
handguns later like I should help up
[ __ ] yeah I'd use the green herb right
now bounce can you go through doors I
don't think so
he's gonna mutated cat some cats milking
others windows oh my god no dogs what
are these things they're like little
urinals you didn't like it I feel like
I'm missing stuff but I have so much
angle if you're supposed to go here yet
I mean
what the hell that's some I really don't
think you're supposed to come off this
way yet I could be wrong listen I've
been wrong many times they're everywhere
need that bow-gun no come on I love this
music yeah
all right where the [ __ ] am I and what
should I do
wait where am I
of course
doesn't look like a safe room door but
I've been wrong before
I don't think I'm supposed to be here I
can't kill these things
oh you're oh there's something over
there well there's something I've on the
mantel behind you if you can dodge him
again
you're feeling lucky I did not get lucky
that time thank you you [ __ ] era's
nice I what am i doing in this [ __ ]
[ __ ] alright it's all these long
arms jerks get away from me what is that
a foot yeah
but a dead person or what what is that
my want a sh
with what is this statue oh I thought it
was like an actual like dead person
whatever I mean I really need that like
help me help you like what what do you
think like is you miss stuff backfires
right but I'm fine I just don't know you
didn't save that long ago so if worse
comes to worse oh ha I don't want to
undo it that would suck - you really
like you're gonna have to come back why
is this taking so
[Music]
I am
revive the family name nice and
the master of the cloth
[Music]
do not worry brother I will handle them
both nice
who's there zoom into the corridor
is it a window brother what is it Alexis
nothing I believe I must have been
imagining things
let us go brother no they did a good job
at making them look sound rich
brother I really don't think you're
supposed to go in there yet well what do
you want me to do do me leave then I
have a [ __ ] ton of handgun bullets
but like
yeah
what's my goal here you need those
octagonal things to put into the
submarine steering wheel thing I think
you have one
you got one envelope and I think you
already put it in so you don't know I
mean I mean you're gonna eventually have
to even if you died and you were just go
back to the saving meal to come back up
here later I don't even think you have
an item that you need to get past year
so if memory serves I played this okay
so I guess what I'm saying is is is it
best if I just leave and go back now
yeah you could check around this room
now that you're here I think it's gonna
do any harm it's that you should not be
backwards yeah it's just a butt massage
card brother good for one massage cuz
they love each other all right all right
this isn't helpful I think bad thing is
a puzzle this blue thing
yes I will this is the farthest you can
go ray I need like the bug yeah alright
cool so let's leave that statue will
turn around and stuff like that okay
that makes sense
let's leave is that what we're doing
we're gonna leave sure
okay we're gonna leave now
outside is [ __ ]
it's got two monsters Bandersnatch is
your lighter slot yeah
they get close to you yeah they like
kiss yeah all right
so also that statue is weird just
hanging there I know it's like a little
seedy god damn it I really hate this
oh my [ __ ] god I can't get past this
guy not dead okay so I'm like in danger
again what should I do
green herb probably do you have anything
in the say box health-wise I think I
have another green herb used there's a
bad guy in this area
maybe he's first aid oh I just feel like
I'm wasting my health or green Arab
tough yeah I don't know she's green herb
good be fine
he'll be in cause I'll be good it's
really stressful like I almost feel like
I should die because I've wasted like
two green herbs I think to do this to go
down this wrong path Lord he's in here
just keep moving
sucked with Bandersnatch
okay so there's a whole [ __ ] another
world in there let's deal with that
later
so you're telling me that I missed
something
it's Steve's area yeah isn't that hanger
right near the worm oh my god I [ __ ]
hanging on that probably and I will this
is gonna hit him
Rizzy god I have no [ __ ] vision
I mean he day I got 180 bullets and I'm
definitely gonna start using them
because I cannot get hurt anymore
where are you [ __ ]
get on the ground right here another one
I could probably dodge this one I'll
just I'm just gonna go now there's a
[ __ ] little dude out here isn't there
my nuts what do you mean little dude I
thought there was like a long arm down
oh Bandersnatch I'm not calling him no
this is the guy went to the bathroom
those are called
I don't know why I felt like I should go
to the bathroom oh Jesus
you Oh Lord oh Lord
ah
King died I thought there were some long
arms out here there are gonna let dogs
left left or right left right will be
the submarine if I'm nervous but I can't
remember where I would be the submarine
go left sorry this right her left okay
god I hope I'm right
because yeah submarines the other right
that's the bridge that you go underneath
long arms here so I need to know where
I'm going like immediately it's like
straight through oh my okay I know right
through that door yeah and then there's
a worm this is a good question obviously
I mean as long as you avoid the worm you
could try each door but I think you're
going through the far side with double
doors it's like here right try that yeah
yeah also I think soon you'll be able
open those doors you just sneak up dodge
the worm use the keycard I don't think
it's okay so we're back here that is
gonna say it's not ventilated I'm pretty
sure yeah double check try that one more
time with the biohazard card okay cool
this is not where you want to be the
where you want to be is when you come
out those double doors so I want to go
back into warm bill yes and then when
you come through them go up that way
toward that camera uh-huh make sure you
dodge the worm uh-huh yeah
sorry they have that door I think this
is good that's where oh my god yeah
double doors when you get when you yeah
circle back for the double doors nice
okay sweet sleeve is okay so handgun
rounds up there just so you have them
how do I get them sorry box behind it no
so I feel like I'm leading you too much
or not what I'm trying to like
Kickstarter remember well I hope you
didn't bring me back here for handgun no
although that would be worth it twelve
of them yeah fifteen sorry that's not
what we came back for I think I'm in a
lot of the door in here that don't think
you use that you need to okay I think
it's that one because I think you
remember you guys fell through the
ceiling together remember these games
are still memory focus time on that
batteries
and a battered or by Steve hey are you
over your dead dad yeah yeah try that
door that's where it came from
okay there's not guy in here you got
handgun rounds up the years oh it's your
unlucky day because I got hand rounds up
the years Oh
who wants some I think they're both dead
hopefully okay have you open that door
yet I mean biohazard card that indigo
it's open oh I don't know I'm pretty
sure this is the area you did not don't
worry my map anymore I didn't explore it
I did like burn through it
Oh in gribbins this is new should I see
no don't a picture of this room Oh
something is like a spot the difference
whoa yeah Kalia
this room makes me uncomfortable you're
missing a picture it looks like I guess
so yeah oh then the Eagle players will
get their ribbons regardless I don't
think it's gonna think of it so it's a
red portrait wait no oh yeah cause with
like a naked person or something holding
something red should I take the ink
ribbons or no yeah cuz it takes up a
slot and they're not gonna save so maybe
I should just leave it no no I thought
you already have a slot filled with ink
ribbons right now so I think that'll
just add to it unless three is the
maximum like look at your inventory if
three already okay I hope I must three
the max don't ya
okay so I'm not saving I don't think so
this is a safe room that we found that's
good
[ __ ] it's dark in here it's really hard
to see Oh what's this this is where are
you and Steve came through is it I think
I could be wrong I can't remember
Oh weird elevator what the [ __ ] can you
use this right now going to the second
floor men's web of a vague recollection
where you need to go with the Eagle
Crest and what they call it Eagle plate
oh wait yes this is actually very close
yeah used you may use my thingy I think
you're actually in the right area yeah
yeah or come back toward the camera
right now what come back toward the
camera right now down this is the second
floor outside that Corey word what's his
name was shooting at you yes Albert yes
his name Albert this is where you want
to be I think I think so like this is
where I fought that guy but like now I
can't get down
oh no your this is right above the your
in the Jeep garage again
oh I'm just on the second floor but I
can't get down right you need to be
remember where else Bert
Albert was shooting at you yes I think
that's where you want to go okay
I remember you have to go back to the
worm courtyard and then through the
double doors in that shutter room really
because the shutter on the other end of
it you can actually use and again this
is all don't get mad if I'm wrong
I mean oh it's time we we have time I'm
not mad I'm just disappointed going to
the basement
wait basement oh is that where you were
no I just wanted to see it's curious
you're been in an old-school elevator
like that like yes you know like New
York has a bunch of them oh is this a
submarine maybe no the submarine is the
other way it's a Dory you're running
into you right now oh wait there's a
walkway there are you the lighting is
pretty bright in here it's so bright I
can't see ya I don't know where this is
gonna go you know it could be cat
catastrophe I don't know what's going on
oh [ __ ] safe where is this who is this
guy
yeah I can't hit you right there I don't
think he'll kill good
yeah
suck bullets
like we're using them I don't know check
it out now oh wait hold on
read that again Oh
breaker may fail due to overload in case
of failure raised lever as ventilation
device will resume reparation member of
that room you couldn't get into behind
the shutters that I had to ventilate
maybe this is your ticket in there oh I
see what you're saying not touch that I
think you need to bail it tried that
machine interactable oh no you have to
go up there it looks like however you
yeah Oh so whatever what card so all the
Indigo ones you can't use there now I'm
not gonna go girl so that seems to be
the overarching thing you should do is
get an indigo card okay or wherever
and none of these guys have one right
well I guess I'm not supposed to be here
yet either we'll call this episode the
episode of going places we are not
supposed to be yes indecision this is
like a tunnel see it come on perfect I
can't go up it like it's a little tube
it's a set of stairs but they seem to be
raised your unique glasses stairs like a
fire escape
oh are they like all right they're like
sideways though yeah well then you can't
sideways them it's like one of those
Airport escalators but not escalating
and standing still now this is called
stairs yeah I'm going to the first floor
and we're going to accomplish something
this episode so help me God
what you got the Eagle plays something
and you cleared kind of cleared the way
yeah but all the like long arms guys I
still can't do any thing about and like
I'm watching oh I have so much in I'm
[ __ ] swarming in it all right where
am I going
swarming in it I need to indigo card for
that
wait what's back to that door B wait did
we go through here what's through that
door that's the Jeep right
which door this is to the garage I think
so
this is where you wanna go okay cool so
you go okay wait hon so to not through
there no no you're going through there
but obviously if the Dodge the worm and
then remember those double doors you
might have to scan the car at while all
right I think you need to just get ready
to open and use the biohazard card hope
it's not an indigo car be there cuz I'm
your [ __ ] oh sorry through there first
where Arthur's here yeah god I hate this
[ __ ] game I'm gonna die
alright so no sorry left left left
yes that's those doors thank you okay so
this should be the ventilation then the
poison room to your left you can't go
through there great you got to go yeah
down that way yeah that's where it's all
backwards so where Albert ambushed you
ambushed took me way too don't give me a
I think this is the right place there is
it there's a doorway out of here
somewhere I believe somewhere you can
use the Eagle press in this courtyard
I'm almost positive
in the courtyard yeah yeah
was it indigo hopefully kind of cyan
sorry I need to go card we did it
so you accomplished something it was
definitely you okay I just open up no
I'm not that that's a good [ __ ] like you
open up a lot of things to do now
remember every door that said indigo
card we can use now
I mean it's Alice had one the way you
just came from near so is this all I
needed
is this the thing that you said I need
you to get or is there something else I
needed
well the Eagle plate was originally and
then that I remembered the courtyard
being something with the flame so where
am I going now the world my oyster I
know you can go back to where Steve just
was that that Paul I had an indigo card
stay awake stay awake bo wait what's in
here I just feel like I'm on edge
everywhere I go yeah that's I think [ __ ]
so you can this is an indoor card reader
I think it's no no no sorry silver yes
okay so I'm gonna tell you something
depressing you could have gotten the
Bogue on way earlier I think from memory
but now you have to wait you're gonna
get it later you have to go through
there for the story anyway okay
but you could have gotten earlier but
you'll be fine anyway you have 180 hanga
I'm doing really well I'm just saying
like where do I go now you can go back
to where the dogs were near that tank
well back to the the door you came
through near where Steve was remember
there's an indigo card reader there and
then there's one of the palace but this
is the worm area yeah I know but go
that way yeah I think there's something
on that barrel back the barrel we got
problems
yeah those double doors so this door you
need some sort of weird concrete key
this door which if you remember threw
that golden Luger door there was like a
half thing I don't know if that's
related but that looked like it but I
don't think you can get it yet anyway
yeah I think you're going through this
door because there's an indigo card
reader through there we can see where
that goes if it's not I think the palace
is the next best bet right you mean like
the boy and girl palace no like there's
an indigo card reader on the first floor
that you haven't seen in a while where
you originally saw the Lugar's and this
is all just a lot of this is me thinking
out loud yeah well at least one of us is
there I'm like I'm just trying to live
man like oh no not here sorry done I
mean it's the same hallway I get like
super lost in these games well I mean
it's tough when you're playing one hour
a week we've yeah okay so I think that
door are doing
that's the elevator elevator and then
that's the way we came
oh that is okay so so so yeah elevator
up to the second floor
wasn't that purple thing with a purple
diamond typewriters probably need to
check it out if you want yeah it was the
typewriter that's the only music so it
was the second floor is that way yeah
his basement was a ventilation or
vice-versa
yeah basement was on the second floor
had a blue card reader right let's go to
the second floor
yeah and then at some point I feel like
I have accomplished enough where I feel
like I should save because I'm starting
to get anxiety that like I'm gonna die
yeah I mean right now even if you die
you haven't like done that much that
stuff but you also know where to go to
do that but I think it'd be fun all
right there you go indigo fighter here I
don't know where this is gonna go but
you have the emblem garden also I think
you can use the emblem card out of the
worm cords do not yeah it was a dead guy
yeah I was really scary what were you
gonna say Lord do not what be a armed
man I don't want to fight them they're
too hard oh I wish I could see if those
audio it was [ __ ] dad scared me I
don't want to die so I have a bunch of
plants what probably use this ooh that
seems important oh I tagging all back
toward the submarine right yes can you
use that computer now that you just pick
that up
oh I don't know is something else in
this room sure brother
I think you're controlling this
there's no time splitters - oddly enough
what am I supposed to be learning is
that the as the painter painting you
want to get to this room if possible go
down farther can you go down a lot
farther is this the ventilation room
then
yeah the poisoned room or whatever it is
I don't know if I'm was earning anything
from the bank you nuts such a good sound
effect that they chose
[Music]
okay can you zoom in oh there you go
special yeah it's gotta be something all
right
well what did the camera I'm sorry the
painting sorry I didn't know you could
zoom in I'm a sexy skeleton that date
11:26 or is that a 1/20 six oh right
that down all right both possibilities
yes please
it's 11 26 is it it just said that okay
Oh excited digitally okay well I got 11
26 written down the bio experiment miss
vintage finished ventilating what no I'm
trying to think I was gonna say oh
that's the password for that office but
you already have that that was 1971
check the rest of us room - you got it
so hey let me ask you this ooh - herbs
right yeah pick him up yeah well I can't
pick them both up I'm almost full so
should I take one and just eat it or
what yeah yeah I would say you do that
and then if I take the other one I'll be
full so I could like leave
Kevin Rafi I don't know if I can I hate
when I can't see them yeah Oh fog bacon
climb stairs normally shoot you in your
butt no stairs for you
I said nope
show me your ID [ __ ] I'm just shooting
the ground
I'm the worst security guard ever
and I won who won bun 216 the album oi
oh sweet another monster fight wait wait
wait
that's an Albert my gosh yeah you it's
like it looks like a vagina and a sperm
yeah it looks like sperm with vagina for
a face and then like hands yes
we've figured it out so it's in its
t-virus which we know and love been so
long come here yeah hug
hey baby elbow yeah give me a kiss right
on the lips oh that was you know that's
not what I meant
let's talk about the other Oh Lord
that's absolutely disgusting I'm gonna
have to bleep that out probably maybe
because they're high mobility and they
discharged electricity alright well
stuff on the floor there oh you don't
have room to you I do if I don't think
those are grenade rounds yeah what do
you want me to do I'm like what can you
do
what's your health at right now it's at
caution use that other green herb
honestly you have enough back in your
box are you in the first day it's great
that you're not gonna use the grenade
rounds will be very well will I come
back to this room I will never come back
to this room because there's another
herb so what I'm saying is this should I
just eat the other herb that's I'm
saying yeah well then I should have
combined the moon yeah whatever
call yourself oh no don't eat it guide
no I'm full oh so you can't get the
grenade rounds no right yeah just use
the ER then we should have combined them
you're fine anyway yeah I love that oh
my god I realize this is my ideal work
I'm not stupid in the best direction but
you're steering me maybe off a cliff
perhaps that room I was in didn't have
storage did it not the painting
typewriter but there's a safe room
relatively close by what should I do
I think you can use that code on the the
door that I was the ventilation room now
okay should I save you first I think my
fear is I know I don't want to do a bus
by sensibly if that what I don't think
you'll have a box I put if I have a be
Fuhrer's floor first floor if that was
anyway no go to the basement maybe know
why cuz through the ventilation give the
army proof I don't know if even the
Wyatt
don't try to use the password on the I
don't feel guided right now oh because I
haven't helped you all today
smash this bottle over my head make you
watch me believe like is this a
punishment for me that's weird
I'm gonna keep
did I need a code in here
I don't need a code in here no I think
you need some sort of card there but I
forgot I could get there that's indigo
it is indigo all right so this isn't
right
so first floor and then try using code
on the first shutter the first she runs
like an idiot she's doing her best she's
just a single girl in a zombie infested
world trying to make her way [ __ ] you
get in that room you're gonna need to
discard something because you're going
to get the skeleton picture oh no that's
all you need yeah I don't like one slot
whatever we go this room really it's not
just so dark
don't think there's more I can see
Mike's face in the reflection and I hate
it all right where am I going I'm
leaving you can see my face I can
yeah double doors and you got it you be
in the tank courtyard with the dogs
great worm and then through the through
the same door you came through I'll tell
you when you get there so my going out
the worm door or am I going to the
double doors whatever one is right here
okay yeah double doors that's so unfair
because I was doing great
how come you can use the bio huh what
was one one two six four then huh
oh you can discard it sick you're done
with the bio housing card I don't think
there's a bad guy in here I'm gonna be
pissed because I've like done a lot no
there's gonna be a boss member you could
have gone in here way back right I think
this is two doors two destinies two
possible deaths mm-hmm two possible stop
spicy Jordan I don't need the spice 1 1
2 6 wait hold on
before this might okay we clearly know
that's probably 1 1 0 okay
now go back if you do the wrong number
of boss is gonna come you just [ __ ]
yourself rxk search the restroom first
okay
a baton okay
I have bows for that does it work
the emergency door lock system in the
biology room can be released with the
four-digit pass I already got it [ __ ] 6
right I came up with an idea you know
the red human skeleton picture in the
back of the biology experiment room I've
decided to use the numbers sign on the
picture as the past number if you happen
to lose the memo just look at the
picture or read this note so everybody
can figure it out well I don't think you
would ever need to use the emergency
pass number anyway but just take it just
in case
mr. careless you big dumb idiot I just
want to try it you might as well I guess
so you get the red skeleton picture you
go back to the typewriter room and pass
the Jeep Niraj and you put it there
hopefully you'll get something new there
[ __ ] what is there was a dead guy in
here remember it was also poisonous but
it's gone now I don't know why cuz you
didn't do the ventilation you think a
resonable game will be logical what am I
getting in here I actually have severe
anxiety [ __ ] what am i doing room here's
a proposal I have no room you don't
here's a proposal yeah
those ink ribbons are killing you don't
need those at all I need those no in
your inventory right now yeah I don't
need them now but I need them in life
you don't have anything [ __ ] what am i
doing is my proposal yeah it was just
head back to a safe room I call that an
episode once you get back and then we go
here because we know we're doing getting
grenades getting the red skeleton
painting going back to put the painting
in and getting whatever that forgives
you okay you already put the steering
wheel in the hawk emblem in the yeah
we're in a good place
I know now you have the other octagonal
yeah there's two doors in here did you
want to try all the other door sure yeah
do that and then we'll go back to the
save room which is
okay well that's too far away it solves
that wait is it locked
there's no doorknob
oh I yeah so go this way this would be
this is quick it's Avery right don't go
back to the palace well we need to put
stuff away right but I'm saying the
quickest save room way what's through
there no don't that's where you got the
explosive rounds for the arrow yeah
through the quarry I just watch the dogs
and you're fine or did that shutter
close so I'm gonna save room upstairs
through here past the dock right see ya
later ya mangy mutt learn how to use
stairs right oh no this is no it's this
one but is the shutter closed I don't
know stops I'm worrying now you're
making me anxious no I think I was
almost there
you almost did it and this one has it
this one has a box of stuff so you can
offload like half year remember yes so I
was so worried we like didn't do things
right but we did geniuses you wanna okay
here's two options you could put away
all the things you don't need or you can
keep this to jog your memory next time
or you can get what you do need I think
any sense keep the indigo card grenades
you don't need right now ink ribbons
once you save you don't need it I don't
need a bow and bullets do I well you're
going to do this once you save anyway so
go save with the increments and then I
meant the bow and the gun oh yeah I
would keep both of them so I should be
good to save it and then next time you
need to end to go car damn oh yeah so we
go back to the
poison room or whatever it was which
somehow got D ventilated ventilated just
by looking at it in the camera unless I
miss something you go back there for the
grenades on the table and we must do
something else with the ventilation yeah
for the basement but you also get the
red skeleton patients go back to that
typewriter not so bad no not so bad for
like flinging walking around not knowing
what I was doing I don't know episode I
was like where am I going
still still got stuff done them happy
Saturday
if you watch this thank you so much for
joining us again yeah I think you guys
are hanging out with us and don't forget
to like him subscribe it helps GameSpot
still do these things you can also
always at me Mary I think my Twitter is
Mary Kish and I'm a hardy I'm gonna roll
the intro again ignore this graphic oh
okay don't look at that graphic but look
at these graphics I can't do that how do
you like these graphics you guys can
message us and let us know what Resident
Evil game you want us to do next
totally burned through code Veronica in
the room let's talk about that while you
brought it up on the penultimate episode
what we're gonna do right it has to be
zero oh I wasn't thinking about oh so I
mean if we go back to Veronica but might
as well do zero I was thinking about
doing Resident Evil sevens DLC I mean
like chronologically we would do
chronologically but like we did one of
it this this is people consider this
like a main main entry but for doing
this I think we should I personally
think we should do 0 and X maybe we
could put up to a vote but zero is also
in the origins collection when you
played remake on the ps4 zero is on that
collection so it's not tank controls
anymore they redid the thumbstick layout
joystick layout analog so you would be
it wouldn't be tank controls but it'd
still be fixed cameras that one's cool
that's a prequel to the first game or
it's like simultaneous remember Rebecca
chambers from the first game she was
that medic in the piano room that you
had to like help or no you were you were
Jill weren't you if you're Chris you
meet her nevermind I'm rambling don't
forget to message us and let us know
what you guys want to do next we're
always interested in more Resident Evil
action Knievel back again next week I
have a good rest of weekend I almost got
killed by that worm but I didn't kill
you got hit once I'll be dramatic it was
the worst day of my life